this week's podcast episode has been
removed and censored from youtube just
one hour after posting i'm of the
opinion that we need free and open
discussion and when doctors and
scientists are censored because they
hold perspectives that don't fit the
current narrative all in the name of
being for our own good a dangerous
precedent is set there's a real group
think problem happening right now and i
see why
scientists with important information
can't properly be heard from the public
so it ends up looking like there's this
one universally agreed upon clear answer
to such a complex issue which is
obviously not the case
you do not want to miss this episode so
head to the ellen fisher podcast on
apple podcast or spotify as you can
still listen to the episode there i am
honored to have gotten to sit down with
this man for an hour conversation his
intelligence and graceful way of
explaining things will blow you away so
click the link below to get to the
episode or go directly to the ellen
picture podcast oh and i will be digging
deeper and doing a whole episode on
censorship coming soon thanks for tuning
in i will see you next episode
[Music]
you